c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie télécharge l'api jeter
gris et tente de remporter jusqu'à un
million d'euros sans rien faire bravo
l'auto facile d'être riche
[Musique]
jean michel vous êtes confiant c'est pas
une équipe pour moi c'est des bouffons
on allait massacrer les couper en
rondelles en août et les tuer on va les
mettre au fond
alors c'est ce qu'on va avoir c'est
parti pour le match de beach volley
laissez-nous passer pavillon de m c'est
bon c'est bien servi encore 1 ou ternir
j'espère qu'il a toi toi c'était un coup
bas c'est une vie en temps allez allez
apparemment c'était un petit peu
compliqué pour nos deux équipes on
remercie les joueurs avaient joué avec
quant à vous vous retrouvez les
chroniqueurs de tpm paix avec ses mains
dans un instant il faut laisser passer
le temps
[Musique]